et
[Musique]
on connaissait l'habitude certains
parents de publier des clichés de leurs
enfants sur facebook ou instagram
aujourd'hui le partage en ligne de sa
vie privée
vinrent cran plus loin de plus en plus
de familles mettent en ligne sur youtube
ce que l'on nomme un blog familiale ou
blogs vidéos les femmes et youtube 'les
deviennent des personnalités qui gagnent
leur vie sur les plateformes de
diffusion
elle montre tous ou presque de leur vie
de tous les jours
la naissance des enfants l'épicerie
hebdomadaire et vacances ou les mauvais
coups des tout petits
ces femmes et s'attire ainsi des
centaines de milliers d'abonnés et leurs
captures sont vu des millions de fois
dans certains cas une notoriété qui
vient avec ses bénéfices les familles
les plus populaires sur youtube récolte
des revenus publicitaires selon la
quantité de visionnement qu'elle génère
elles vendent des produits dérivés ou
signent des ententes avec des grandes
marques
alléchés par de tels auditoire sans
surprise la commercialisation de ces
moments autrefois intime en fait
sourciller plus d'un
notamment en ce qui a trait au respect
de la vie privée de ses enfants parfois
suivis par une caméra depuis leurs
premiers jours de vie
[Musique]